maintenant pour continuer la discussion
on est avec Charles Côté notre ami
avocat criminalisme bonjour Charles
bonjour Isabelle
évidemment qui sont menées de front on
va parler d'abord de ces plaintes qui
ont été faites à la police on parle de
d'une accusation mais d'une plainte pour
voiture une plainte pour intimidation
expliquez-nous ce que ça peut être des
voix de fait on n'est pas obligé de
frapper non effectivement tout le monde
va comprendre que le voie de fait
traditionnel c'est l'utilisation de la
force sur une autre personne contre sa
volonté mais parfois simplement de je
vous dirais là d'aller dans la bulle
d'une personne d'une façon menaçante et
intimidante surtout dans un cadre de
une relation
de professeur étudiants ça peut
effectivement constituer un voie de fait
alors si la personne a une crainte
raisonnable que ce qui se manifeste
devant elle peut de transformer en des
coûts en des voies de fait on peut
imaginer particulièrement pour un enfant
si petit
enfant de 11 ans là on parle de ces
âges-là
première année il me semble que c'est
sept ans
c'est possible mais je vous dirais que
ça crée un climat assez intimidant pour
les enfants
suffisamment pour créer une crainte
raisonnable de votre fait oui
intimidation c'est pas absolument lié
par exemple au crime organisé
c'est toute une façon un comportement et
si dans le camp à l'espèce sont les cris
répétés
dirigé directement à la classe ou à
certains étudiants qui font en sorte que
un climat d'intimidation vraiment le
professeur cherche à imposer sa façon de
faire
clients et ces règlements à la classe
bon évidemment ici les enfants ont
imagine qu'il devait s'en plaindre à
leurs parents de ce qui se passait dans
la classe les parents devaient pas en
croire leurs oreilles alors on a vu que
un ou des parents qui ont fourni un
dispositif d'enregistrement à un enfant
est-ce qu'il fallait absolument
enregistrer pour obtenir la preuve
est-ce que des témoignages d'enfants de
7 ans ou de première année aurait suffi
ou c'est encore mieux parce que c'est
appuyé c'est sûr que effectivement vous
l'avez dit c'est toujours mieux
lorsqu'on a une preuve
indépendante et disons que c'est
difficile de contester ce genre de
preuves là mais le témoignage des
enfants aurait été suffisant pour
déclencher une enquête interne à tout le
moins qui aurait permis de pouvoir le
constater et écoutez tout le monde a
entendu les enregistrements on entend ça
c'est pas vrai que les classes ont une
insonorisation à tout épreuve c'est
évident que d'autres professeurs
du personnel ont pu l'entendre et si je
ne m'abuse il y a même un enfant d'une
classe adjacente qui en a parlé à ses
parents à l'effet qu'il entendait la
professeur crier bon là je parle à un
avocat droit criminel mais quand même
est-ce que c'est absolument nécessaire
que cette affaire-là pense par la
justice criminelle passe par la police
de se retrouvent devant les tribunaux
criminels je sais pas je veux pas porter
un jugement de valeur mais est-ce que
c'est absolument cette extrémité là
qu'il faut atteindre disons que c'est
peut-être excessif d'arriver à se
recourt là immédiatement je pense que en
matière disciplinaire il y a des
mécanismes qui encadrent les professeurs
et par une plainte à la direction mais
de ce que on peut comprendre aussi c'est
que la direction n'aurait pas réagi à
des plaintes antérieures alors est-ce
que c'est plutôt justement par dépit
qu'on a décidé de d'aller
voir les policiers avec une preuve
disons somme toute béton c'est le
problème mais s'il y avait une écoute
peut-être un peu plus proactive au
niveau de la direction locale peut-être
qu'une enquête interne aurait pu aider à
déterminer si il y avait un manquement à
l'honneur et elle a dignité de la
profession de d'enseignants et à partir
de ce moment-là engagé des procédures
disciplinaires contre ce professeur là
il nous reste peu de temps mais est-ce
que toutes ces enquêtes qui vont aller
de front qui vont être menées peuvent
entrer en collision cette nuit ou au
contraire céder la théoriquement en ce
qui tout ce qui concerne le droit
criminel on doit chercher à éviter
d'être contaminé par une preuve qui a
été obtenue contre le gris de la
personne qui est visée on s'entend dans
des enquêtes disciplinaires souvent la
personne visée doit collaborer à
l'enquête et doit fournir des réponses
doit répondre aux questions qui lui sont
posées ce n'est pas le même standard en
matière criminelle et les policiers
devraient
naturellement garder ça de côté et ne
pas se servir du fruit de ces enquêtes
là mais on va suivre ça merci infiniment
Charles Côté
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI